[Musique]
bonsoir à tous quel plaisir de vous
retrouver c'est ça vous regarde
en direct c'est la troisième saison
c'est reparti voici le sommaire notre
grand témoin ce soir est un médecin
engagé sur tous les fronts la crise
sanitaire la laïcité la lutte contre
l'islamisme il était le premier sur les
lieux de la tuerie charlie-hebdo cinq
ans après les attentats comment vit-il
ce procès historique patrick peloux et
notre grand témoin ce soit avec lui nous
évoquerons la crise de nerfs dans la
majorité la république en marche semble
être à l'arrêt des missions d affection
échecs électoraux et si l'étiquette l
hérault m était devenu synonyme de
défaite c'est la question du face à face
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission mais on commence tout de suite
avec le grand débat il concerne
l'écologie et l'agriculture faut-il
réintroduire les pesticides tueurs
d'abeilles pour sauver certaines
filières le projet de loi sur les
néonicotinoïdes divise on en parle tout
de suite avec nos invités
[Musique]
voilà la bei ou la betterave c'est le
choix cornélien que vont devoir faire
les députés bonsoir jean baptiste moreau
bienvenue sur ce plateau ravi de vous
retrouver vous êtes député la république
en marge de la creuse député
agriculteurs et porte parole de ce
projet de loi sur les néonicotinoïdes
difficile à prononcer mais difficile à
porter aussi temps eh bien ils suscitent
de critiques parmi les écologistes dont
vous faites partie à samuel l'airé
bonsoir leur et pardonnez moi vous êtes
le porte parole de la fondation nicolas
hulot le directeur scientifique de deux
pour l' agriculture de l'inra et viendra
nous rejoindre dans un instant monsieur
christian huyghe et bonsoir patrick
peloux reçoit merci d'être là je suis
sûr que le médecin que vous êtes a plein
de choses à dire en matière de santé sur
sur les pesticides médecin urgentiste au
samu de de paris médecin engagé je le
disais on va évoquer tout à l'heure un
peu plus tard dans l'émission évidemment
le procès de charlie hebdo vous avez
même témoigné un jeu leur appel devant
la cour d'assises spéciale de paris on
en vient dans un instant parlera aussi
de delà de la crise sanitaire mais on ne
change pas une équipe qui gagne
qu'est-ce qu'on avait gagné je ne me
souviens même plus entonné c'est la
saison dure voilà exactement à mes côtés
scheer à vis de vous retrouver si j'ai
bien compris c'est maintenant alors les
néonicotinoïdes qu avez-vous compris à
ce dossier
si j'ai bien compris il se trouve qu'en
france les ministre de l'écologie si je
me trompe les mises et l'écologie ont
exactement le même régime alimentaire
que les hérons cendrés et hérons cendrés
oui en cendres et les oiseaux sachs a
pas eu ce que ces gars on sent dès lors
je vous montre garnier belles photos
voyez ça c'est celle donc le héros
sétoise au long bec en manche et d'un
long cou qui a cette capacité d'avaler
des couleuvres mais des couleuvres mais
exactement comme ministre de l'écologie
en france
c'est marrant cette barre à l'est parce
que alors c'est pas nouveau un par
exemple déjà en 2012
nkm souvenez-vous ministre l'écologie de
sarkozy voilà dans la presse qu'on a
bien remarqué qu'elle avait quand même
un goût pour les couleurs
en tout cas que la balle est pas mal
mais ça vaut pas que pour elle ça vaut
pour tous les ministres ensuite sous
volant il ya eu bel philippe batoux
alors des couleuvres elle en aval et
elle manque un moment voilà on a redouté
qu'elle fasse une indigestion
n'envoyez c'était d'ailleurs le titre
d'un article qui lui était consacrée
puis vous souvenez aussi le plus récent
c'était donc le premier ministre de
l'écologie de mme emmanuel macron
nicolas hulot donc cool d'abord le matin
dans mes bras fourcou la presse nick et
couleuvres ans au foyer à un moment il a
dit non ça ça va être l'indigestion jeu
presque proposé ma démission et ça va
être la même chose même régime
couleuvres pour barbara pompili alors je
passais pas démissionner je ne serai pas
évidemment mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
pour les couleurs bon ça y est elle a
commencé déjà à prendre des petites
couleurs comme ça en apéro à la lèvre ça
fait trois mois qu'il est là et elle est
déjà commencée en aval et quelques-unes
je sais que l'histoire barbares mon fils
il était donc ministre de l'ecologie
sous françois hollande elle a fait voter
un projet de loi difficilement la eu
beaucoup de courage pour ça pour
interdire l'utilisation de ce fameux
néonicotinoïdes qui ont la fâcheuse
capacité de tuer
les abeilles et donc au jeu à l'époque
quand elle était la présence de ces bois
à l'assemblée est elle à la tribune de
l'assemblée pour expliquer pourquoi
c'était vraiment très important mais
vraiment très important d'avoir une date
butoir dans cette loi à partir de
laquelle on était sûr qu on
n'utiliserait plus jamais donné au no
kinoïde négo nicotinamide alors
l'écoutent
à ce moment là pourquoi c'était très
important d'avoir cette date butoir
couperet c'est parce que si on commence
à dire on interdit là où il ya des
alternatives mais on fait des
dérogations et on les laisse courir dans
le temps on sait très bien que ça c'est
la porte ouverte au fait qu' il y ait
certains néo nicotine lui qu'il ne soit
jamais interdit ben voilà quatre ans
plus tard ben arfa est de retour au
ministère de l'écologie est elle vient
d'accepter ce qu'elle a dit vouloir
éviter à tout prix
quatre ans auparavant c'est à dire
qu'elle a autorisé ou la majorité en
tous cas devrait voter une dérogation
qui va permettre aux producteurs de
betteraves sucrières de continuer à
utiliser ces fameuses insecticide tueur
d'abeilles pendant encore trois ans
alors si ça c'est pas une belle couleurs
appétissantes un miam miam ça tout est
alors comment se fait-il que cette date
butoir finalement n'est pas été
respectées ah bah ça c'est la france
vous savez que quand on vote une loi ce
n'est pas tout en france on a souvent du
mal à la faire appliquer froide le foehn
a dit que seules 72% des lois votées
sont appliquées donc en l'occurrence on
avait laissé deux ans producteurs de
betteraves pour trouver une solution de
remplacement au néonicotinoïdes en longs
qui le chercher je ne sais pas en tout
cas ils n'ont pas trouvé les résultats
maintenant il n'y a pas d'autre solution
que d'accorder cette dérogation est
pourquoi finalement barbara pompiers 10
acceptent d'accorder cette dérogation et
la pauvre mais là pas le choix qu'est ce
que voulez vous saviez peut-être pas moi
je le savais pas avant de m'intéresser
au sujet la france est le premier
producteur de sucre en europe
donc on peut être fier de ça c'est une
filière importante 46 mille emplois en
jeu donc si on n'utilise pas assez et
néonicotinoïdes ça peut faire baisser la
production de betteraves jusqu'à 40 50 %
donc pour faire notre sucre dont on est
si fier froid qu'on achète des
betteraves donc à l'étranger dans des
pays où on les fait pousser justement en
utilisant d insecticide toxique donc
quand on our des ministres pourquoi il a
accordé la drogue la dérogation bah
voilà ce qu'il répond parce que c'est
une question de souveraineté
d'indépendance
moi je veux pas laisser tomber la
filière de la betterave et que demain
mes enfants ne mangent que du sucre
belges ou allemands
et en plus sont produits avec des
productions et des produits qui sont
bien pires que les nôtres
alors voyez c'est ça le drame si on ne
veut pas que nos enfants mangent du
sucre allemand et ça serait quand même
un drame est bien dans ce cas il faut
que barbara d'eau pompili avaler
quelques couleuvres je crois que c'est
ce qu'elle a fait merci stéphane je vous
en prie ne se rendent pas compte
jean-baptiste moreau quelle couleuvre
quelle couleuvre tout de même pour
barbara compilé on va rentrer dans le
détail 1 de ce dossier mais quand on
l'entend il ya quatre ans et qu'on voit
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe sur ce
dossier on se dit voilà il a raison
stéphane blakowski collègues de plus il
a pas raison parce que justement le fait
de l'inscrire dans la loi on a supprimé
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui 90 % et même avec les
dérogations on aura supprimé 90% des
usages des néonicotinoïdes on n'a pas
donné pas à 100% avec si on met en place
cette dérogation
mais on aura quand même supprimer 90 %
des usages je le répète à l'époque les
néonicotinoïdes sait utiliser non
seulement en enrobage de semences mais
aussi en pulvérisation
ce qui n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui et
la dérogation elle va aller uniquement
dans un temps limité sur trois ans c'est
ce que disait barbara pompili elle
disait il faut pas des dérogations sans
limite de temps parce que effectivement
les dérogations sans limite de temps ça
devient une loi générale
alors vous allez trois ans c'est
suffisant pour trouver une alternative
c'est d'ailleurs la question que je vais
sûrement vous poser au cours de ce débat
bonsoir christian huyghe
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
directeur scientifique pour l'
agriculture à l'inra eux ont dit inra
veut maintenant c'est l'institut
national de la recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement avant d'entrer dans le
détail parce qu'il est un peu technique
ce dossier une petite réaction le
citoyen sur la parole politique quand on
entend comme saïd ministre se dédire on
peut continuer à croire en la politique
faut croire en la politique si vous ne
croyez plus en la politique vous croyez
plus en la démocratie en la république
il faut croire faut croire en la
répétant la politique il faut croire en
la répu en la politique qui écoute les
autres qui arrivent à avoir des
compromis et qui arrive à écouter des
personnalités qui porte justement une
envie que l'on voit s'être concrétiser
dans les urnes
c'est plus d'écologie d'accord et donc
en effet défendre lé infiniment petit
c'est défendre des insectes qui a plus
d'un c'est qu'il ya plus de vie sur
terre donc d'un coup les abeilles site
absolument c'est symbolique d'accord
mais
derrière les abeilles vous avez aussi
les fourmis etc je me souviens d'avoir
lu une étude sur l'appauvrissement de la
terre et j'en profite juste pour faire
une parabole sur défendre le monde
universitaire de la biologie des
insectes
parce que justement ils sont dans une
très grande souffrance et la france
était vraiment leader sur cette
recherche des insectes et de la vie de
cette vie infinie est juste une
parenthèse cc c'est bien mais quand vous
allez dans les jardineries et que vous
voyez tous ces insecticides et
pesticides que les gens peuvent acheter
et que le lait nos concitoyens ont accès
à ces produits qui sont extrêmement
dangereux pour leur propre existence et
leur propre santé donc je pense qu'en
effet il n'ya pas de petits insecticides
et de il faut vraiment légiférer là
dessus on va empêcher on va entrer à
présent dans ce dossier y at il des
bombes insecticides des mauvais
insecticides faut-il faire le tri y at
il des alternatives
on va aussi regarder de près à quoi
ressemble une betterave quand elle est
privée de ceux fameuse insecticides les
néonicotinoïdes qu'est ce que c'est si
les sujets pardonnez-moi cinéma et
terrain pour alexis cultivateurs de
betterave sucrière dans le nord de la
france il suffit de regarder sa récolte
pour comprendre dans sa main gauche une
betterave en bonne santé
dans l'autre une betterave deux fois
plus petites dont la quasi-totalité des
feuilles sont jaunies pour l'agriculteur
le constat est clair sur 50 hectares de
sa production
il va devoir en jeter une bonne partie
on va avoir
dans les rendements des chutes de
rendements de l'ordre pour l'instant
estimée à 30% mais sans doute plus
suivant les zones une culture mise à mal
due à une maladie transmise par le
puceron vers un fléau que seul un
insecticide peut vaincre pour le moment
pour ce produit pas d'épandage les
néonicotinoïdes enrobe la petite graine
le problème c'est qu'il est interdit en
france depuis deux ans en raison
notamment de son effet destructeur sur
les abeilles sur la biodiversité mais
également sur les êtres humains pour
sauver la filière menacé le gouvernement
est prêt à revenir en arrière avec la
présentation d'un projet de loi
l'objectif est clair demander des
dérogations pour le secteur de la
betterave
mais avec des conditions bien
spécifiques moi je veux bien qu'on dise
qu'on ferme toutes les sucreries en
france pourquoi pas c'est un choix
politique
le choix qui a été fait c'est d'essayer
de les garder ses sucreries et pour les
garder il faut qu'on ait des betteraves
et pour qu'on ait des betteraves il faut
qu on en plante et pour qu on en plante
il faut qu'il y ait une solution face à
ce puits seront usage du pesticide
pourrait donc être à nouveau autorisé
jusqu'en 2023
à titre dérogatoire le règlement
européen n'y autorise on ne parle que
des betteraves on ne on ne parle d'une
dérogation que si on a un hiver doux
serre si l'hiver n'est pas doux et bien
il n'y aura pas de néonicotinoïdes sur
sur les betteraves
on parle de limitation d'entente
le gouvernement souhaite également
mettre en place un plan d'action pour
sécuriser les plantations et prévoit
l'indemnisation pour les pertes de
rendements les plus importantes de la
campagne passée du à la jaunisse
mais malgré tout les inquiétudes
persistent alors les inquiétudes
justement samuel leur et parlez nous en
on comprend très bien
déjà les problèmes sur les abeilles on
voit la difficulté expliquez-nous déjà
en quoi c'est un problème qu'il n'y ait
plus de pollinisation
pour ceux qui ne le savent pas forcément
les pollinisation en agriculture c'est
ce qui permet à 85 % de toutes les
plantes de pouvoir se nourrir donc on a
besoin des abeilles on a besoin des
pollinisateurs ce qui se passe et ça on
l'oubli quand on parle des
néonicotinoïdes c'est qu'il ya 80% des
insectes en europe qui ont disparu
depuis 30 ans donc on est déjà dans une
destruction de masse et donc on sait que
les néonicotinoïdes quand ils ont été
mis en place à partir des années 90 les
colonies d'abeilles ont diminué de 30%
donc c'est de ça qu'on parle
actuellement donc c'est les abeilles
écosystèmes et aussi quoi les oiseaux
parce qu' il peut y avoir un problème
dans l'air dans les sols expliquez-nous
jusqu où est le danger est ce qu on le
sait alors ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on ne
sait pas tout ce qu'on sait c'est que
dans les menus nicotine ç'a bien été
montré
leno nicotine odile sont mis ils sont
enrobées donc sonné semences enrobées
il faut savoir c'est que la plante de
l'épandage pour enlever leur erdf c'est
pas le monde santo glyphosate des choses
puisque ce muscat important de savoir
c'est que 80% de la substance active
donc des néonicotinoïdes ne reste pas
sur la place sur la fleur mais va bien
dans le sol dans les eaux et donc après
va polluer tout le reste outre toute la
biodiversité et donc ça c'est essentiel
d'avoir ça en tête puis jusqu'à juste un
mot parce qu'avant on a parlé des
couleuvres avalées par bara barbara
pompidou moi ce que je voudrais rappelé
qu'en 2010 est déjà stéphane travert à
l'époque était ministre de l'agriculture
avait déjà demandé une dérogation
l'avait il l'avait annoncé nicolas hulot
s'il était opposé
donc c'est bien aussi des choix
politiques qui sont faits et là on parle
d'un véritable recul en matière
d'environnement comme ça n'a pas été le
cas depuis très très longtemps recul
vous allez répondre vous promet jean
baptiste moreau mais christian huyghe on
ne vous a pas encore entendu sur ce
danger la biodiversité est menacée est
ce qu'on sait s'il ya des effets
sanitaires sur l'homme sur l'humain on
revient un médecin sur le plateau donc
je vais pas me risquer sur sur la
problématique de l'impact sur l'humain
en fait comme ça vient d'être dit en
fait on est face à des à des complexes
vieux des éco systèmes biologiques
extrêmement complexe donc effectivement
si on a un impact sur les insectes on a
un impact sur les oiseaux qui n'ont plus
d'insectes à manger qui peuvent plus
nourrir leurs petits
vous avez en fait l'ensemble d'une
biodiversité qui
qui est perturbé et il finit vous pouvez
avoir ce des impacts directs sur
l'humain si on a quand même relativement
peu sur des impacts conditions d'accès
d'accès au marché par contre vous avez
des impacts indirects parce que vous
avez ddd cocktail de molécules auquel
vous être exposés et le cercle où le
mentionner clairement tout à l'heure
dans les jardineries ou même quand vous
allez dans votre rayon de supermarché
vous avez vous acheté des produits pour
l'entretien de votre maison qui sont
autant de molécules ou qu'elle vous êtes
exposé donc ça compte ça construit des
expos zone chimiques complexes qui ont
un impact sur la santé et des impacts
qui peuvent être très complaisant que ce
qu'on doit réfléchir c'est derrière
cette histoire là on pourra revenir
après plus précisément sur la betterave
les pucerons et les virus mais c'est ce
qui met en tension ce qui est un bien
privé parce qu'il faut se nourrir et se
nourrir le moins cher possible et les
agriculteurs doit vivre et ce qui est un
bien commun la biodiversité pour
aujourd'hui mais aussi la biodiversité
pour demain c'est ça qui est au coeur de
ce débat on le comprenait des questions
de dire que les néonicotinoïdes ne sont
sans danger sont sans danger par contre
dire que la biodiversité chute deux buts
effondrement de la biodiversité qui est
une catastrophe qui est une véritable
catastrophe en premier pour les
agriculteurs parce que les
pollinisateurs il permet de la
fécondation des des plantes et notamment
la formation des fruits donc évidemment
qu'ils sont indispensables mais elle
n'est pas dû qu'à la cacophonie et
nicotine aux idées même elle n'est pas
dû qu'à l'agriculture
elle est due aussi à l'urbanisation
parce que ça on en parle c'est plus
facile de stigmatiser 400 mille
agriculteurs que d'expliquer jambon des
pesticides des agriculteurs en général
je dirais baptisé 400 mille agriculteurs
que d'expliquer que la chute de la
biodiversité elle est due au mode de vie
de 60 millions de français ou de 70
millions de français ou de
des milliards d'êtres humains et
pourtant c'est ça la vérité la chute de
la biodiversité l ai dû effectivement
aux produits phytosanitaires qui ont été
réduits au cours des dernières années et
qui vont être réduits je répète
néonicotinoïdes 90 % si globalement si
les plus d'an giang en attendant général
région état tendance générale est à la
réduction
oui alors pourquoi c'est vital pour les
brises ravier d'avoir cette loi de
dérogation c'est si vous avez des
d'aider des gens qui nous regardent
qu'ils comprennent pas pourquoi on veut
à nouveau leur mettre un pesticide
qu'est ce que vous voulez si vous si
vous diminuer de 20 à 30% rendement
l'année d'après le betteravier il plante
autre chose parce qu'ils sont pas que
betteraviers il se hisse en polyculture
ils ont ils ont différentes cultures
c'est l'âge où ils vont perdre de
l'argent et l'april ne la planque plus
ils implantent plus les sucreries tourne
plus si elles tombent plus les gens sont
au chômage et on supprime toute la
filière et on aurait un plan pas la
fille est rentrée mais c'est pas pour ça
effectivement mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'il faut mettre en danger la santé des
français et là ce que je veux dire aussi
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
raconte sur les néonicotinoïdes d'abord
donc on supprime 90% je rappelle il y
aura que 10 % qui seront concernés par
cette dérogation pour trois ans je
rappelle que cinq emplois je réponds bah
il sera à la sortie de l'examen c'est
notre boulot de parlementaires j'aurai
je rappelle que on peut pas dire à la
fois que les néonicotinoïdes son
rémanents et qu'à la fois il se retrouve
dans le sol c'est des organochlorés il
se fixe à l'argile et donc ils sont très
peu lessivé donc il se retrouve très peu
dans les eaux au final globalement mais
par contre ils sont rémanents dans le
sol oui c'est vrai le temps de demi vie
c'est à dire le temps où la moitié du du
des néonicotinoïdes et et supprimer ces
200 jours donc c'est pour ça que dans
les décrets d'application il y aura le
fait qu'on ne met pas de plantes à
fleurs tout de suite après une betterave
et même l'année qui suit encore on en
mettra pas pour justement que les
néonicotinoïdes soient nettoyées et que
et la betterave ne fleurit pas donc les
abeilles ne viennent pas se poser sur la
betterave par contre cette année
l'alternative parce qu'il n'y avait pas
ces néonicotinoïdes c'est qu'on a
pulvérisé des insecticides qui eux par
contre tu tous les insectes qui sont
présents sur ce serait un moindre mal
c'est ce que vous nous dites c'est un
moindre mal
c'est un accompagnement vers la
transition mais ça ne veut pas dire que
c'est une dérogation advitam eternam
c'est sur trois ans et après il faut
trouver d'autres solutions que
que les néonicotinoïdes alors quelle
solution parce que là on arrive sur le
point d alternatives y avait deux en
2016 loi pompili biodiversité 2018 début
de l'interdiction il y avait deux ans
pour trouver des alternatives faire
marcher la recherche
vous représentez l'inra que fut la
recherche pourquoi n'y a pas eu
davantage de solutions proposées alors
vous faites la question telle que vous
la posez en fait on peut la traiter de
façon mais quand vous dites il ya t'il
une solution vous fait passer l'idée que
on enlève les néonicotinoïdes et on
mettra une autre option uniquement une
seule en face et en fait sa une au
plaisir cette approche par la
substitution en fait c'est un peu ce qui
est la limite de notes de notre système
il faut obligatoirement repensait
plusieurs leviers en même temps et c'est
pour ça que c'est complexe et que ça
prend du temps et qu'aujourd'hui on n'a
pas effectivement comme le mini cela dit
on n'a pas de deux d'alternative
opérationnel a fait ce que font les
chercheurs expliquent et nous il ya des
molécules
on essaye est-ce qu'il faut essayer sur
une saison si ça marche pas bah tant pis
alors du coup c'est la saison qui donc
face à la poubelle comment ça se passe
concrètement cette recherche parce qu'on
se dit finalement les législateurs donne
du temps et puis rien ne se passe on est
obligé de faire des dérogations non
c'est pas rien que suppose faut pas dire
ça
les caricatures quand vous dites on va
tester des molécules vous restez dans le
monde de la chimie est donc le monde de
la chimie
face à un insecte ça consiste à le tuer
et on ne répond absolument pas aux
problématiques de biodiversité et donc
la question elle est comment on passe de
ça à une situation où il ya des
régulations biologique qui fonctionnent
elles réelles sont les pistes qui
existent pour avoir des régulations
biologique il faut favoriser la présence
d'auxiliaires sondés des coccinelles des
sièges des crises ont remonté le niveau
de biodiversité de l'ensemble du monde
agricole
ça suppose d'avoir aussi à côté des
parcelles de betteraves des endroits où
cette biodiversité peut exister parce
que vous aurez pas d'auxiliaire ci a pas
un endroit des pucerons à manger et donc
c'est un changement d'organisation des
paysages et l'école un changement de la
composition des cultures et c'est aussi
travailler sur les variétés pour qu'elle
soit plus résistant honnêtement vous
avez trois ans pour la filière betterave
qui pourra utiliser avec des amendements
vous serez vigilant on a entendu le
point de vue la majorité ça suffira pour
trouver une alternative ou 7 de tout et
c'est toujours très difficile de prédire
le futur et donc on a un certain nombre
on a augmenté la part
deux solutions convoi qui vont être
mobilisés pour ça entre l'inra et d'une
part et l'institut technique de la
betterave et les professionnels du monde
des semences c'est comment on explore
beaucoup de levier qu'on doit mettre en
systèmes pour réussir à obtenir cet
objectif que que les chercheurs mais
aussi l'ensemble des profiteurs
attendent et dans tous les cas de toute
façon il faut réussir pour faire monter
les régulations logique il faudra
obligatoirement réussir à avoir plus de
biodiversité dans les paysages agricoles
obligatoires les écolos alors vous
représentez nous on wheels agriculture
écologie je pense que c'est une erreur
je pense que sur ça on va se on va sur
rejoindre celle de choses qui doivent
sur lequel on doit avancer de manière
concomitante mais en fait je trouve
aussi composent le débat dans mauvais
termes
là sur la betterave si on prend au
niveau national parce qu'on a dit qu' on
n'a lui plus une destruction d'emplois
c'est une baisse de rendement au niveau
national de 8 5% à la récolte est pas
fait donc on sait pas exactement
l'inversé les chiffres officiels pour le
moment de l'institut de l'institut
technique de la betterave qui n'est pas
parti on comprend bien il ya un énorme
manque à gagner non 5% en agriculture
c'est pas énorme l'agriculture dit pas
de bêtise qui a été très mauvaise à
cause en partie une baisse de rendement
de 8,5 pour cent
nous ce qu'on propose à la fondation
nicolas hulot c'est une pro une
proposition de dire bon des dommages ont
les agricultures cette année sur la
perte de rendement une boîte à les
dédommager comme on fait d'habitude
c'est à dire de leur donner de l'argent
comme ça on va échos conditionné et éco
conditionner les aides qu'est ce que ça
veut dire l'écoconditionnalité leur dire
on va vous dédommager mais en échange
vous allez commencer à investir sur ces
solutions puisqu'il ya des pistes qu'on
connaît déjà notamment le passage à la
crau écologie la première éco condition
qu'on propose c'est de retarder la date
des semis ce qu'on se rend compte que en
matière de betteraves
on plante de plus en plus tôt et un
moment donné où il n'y a rien pour
protéger des pucerons donc ça affaiblit
et la plante donc on peut avec la date
de semences éviter l' attaque des
pucerons et donc peut-être la jaunisse
des betteraves sans sens en avoir on m'a
dit monsieur c'est une certaine la
solution c'est pas la totalité de la
solution il faut aussi pouvoir planter
des haies qui vont permettre
d'accueillir des coccinelles justement
ton manger les pucerons réunion il faut
quatre ans pour le faire pousser 4,5
schuster pour la mettre en place donc
c'est pas classe le refuge le refus
belgique et les aides de toutes façons
vous n'allez pas le problème c'est ça
c'est que l'aide d'abord elle peut pas
être à 100% parce que c'est contraire au
droit européen ça c'est là c'est comme
ça on peut le regretter mais c'est comme
ça et de toute façon si vous si le on va
dire si ce que l'agriculteur gagne nenê
suspendu qu'au fait qu'il ait des z ou
qui n'est pas dead il va pas implanter
cette culture là il va faire autre chose
et donc une qui fait autre chose ça veut
dire qu'on aura moins de betteraves
c'est ça le problème de base c'est
qu'aujourd'hui si des agriculteurs ne
plante pas là au printemps prochain des
betteraves l'année prochaine et qu en
europe d'autres l'utilisent ce pays
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut pas le
faire pourrait taxer au fond notre brave
pour pour essayer de faire en sorte que
haute celle des étrangers pour essayer d
importer mais ça ne s'est pas possible
en europe
non mais on est sur un marché commun ces
formations européennes
je suis les importations de d'autres
pays sur lesquels on pourrait enfin la
notion exportateur net de son ex porte
en attaque c'est ce qu'on apporte
sachant qu'on ne porte pas les
souverainetés
ce n'est pas une question de
souveraineté puisque la moitié de ce
qu'on produit est exportée donc on
produit du sucre non pas pour le marché
français dont il faut pas s'inquiéter
les petits français et continuera à
manger du sucre français oui maintenant
non pas que sa position détruit la
filière y aura plus de sucre français on
importera la filière s'est elle va elle
va pas se maintenir à coup de
subventions publiques ça n'existera pas
ça il y aura d'autres productions qui
vont prendre la place il y aura plus de
betteraves produite et on en exportera
plus effectivement mais on en importera
parce que on en fabriquera plus c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas façon si les
agriculteurs ne plante plus de
betteraves
il n'y aura plus de bt à la question
derrière ce débat c'est ce qu'ont font
l'agriculture peuvent se passer de ces
pesticides et de ces insectes cibles
aujourd'hui il ya dans la terreur dans
la filière des autres est-ce que vous
pouvez en place et d'antibiotiques
savoir savoir je peux vous réponds tu es
là dessus parce que le sucre c'est paco
la mettra ses produits phytosanitaires
qui failli éliminer ceux qui sont
dangereux pour l'homme oui évidemment
évidemment et éliminer les plus
dangereux ouï dire qu'on va se passer
totalement produits phytosanitaires
phytosanitaires ça dit bien ce que ça
veut dire contrairement aux pesticides
ces deux des produits de soins
aux plantes donc dire qu'on va arrêter
de soigner les plantes
enfin je veux dire c'est cette annonce
ans mais après il ya des moyens et des
techniques agronomiques et l'agro
écologie permis de réduire
considérablement les doses non mais je
permet de réduire considérablement les
autres et à l'agriculture biologique
totalement pas totalement il ya besoin
aussi en agriculture biologique d'un
certain nombre de produits de protection
qui met fin au déficit de synthèse ben
oui mais naturelle le lac hall d'accueil
le colchique est et est un produit
naturel qui est parmi les plus forts
poison au monde donc je veux dire c'est
pas parce que cette synthèse ou naturel
que c'est bon ou mauvais lieu enfin
voila il s'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça christian muys comment vous
regardez ce débat vous êtes celui qui
représente la recherche scientifique
ça urge ces alternatives et on voit que
le temps scientifique n'est pas le temps
politique et le temps citoyens ils
peuvent se réconcilier ces deux camps là
ou pas comme ça c'est leur problème je
dis c'est toujours non et l'agriculture
mais la question elle est là le quelle
est la vision que l'on a sur le futur
c'est quoi le futur désirable qu'on se
construit c'est quoi le projet le
contrat social autour de ça et le
contrat social de demain il
obligatoirement il conte cyril devra
concilier la performance économique
sinon on ne mange pas on ne vit pas et
la performance environnementale
il faut cesser de là elle ne peut pas
s'en passer si vous dites demain matin
j'en laisse tout ça ne marche pas par
contre la question vous posiez à la
recherche qu'est ce que l'on fait on est
en train de porter aujourd'hui un
programme prioritaire de recherche qui
qui ciblent le zéro pesticide et à
explorer des leviers qu'on n'avait pas
aujourd'hui on a exploré la génétique
depuis un certain temps et on doit
continuer à le faire mais par exemple la
découverte de ce qu'est le microbiote il
ya un microbiote autour des plantes dont
on ignorait à peu près tous deux des
fonctions aujourd'hui ça devient un
levier pour protéger les cultures on ne
connaissait pas jusqu'à ya quelques
années le fait que les insectes se
déplace grâce à un paysage olfactif qui
a pas le bout joli mot d'écologie
chimique mais le paysage olfactif et
donc le fait de découvrir ça se fait
qu'on peut construire les paysages qui
fait que les insectes tout en les
préservant ils vont voir ailleurs et pas
causé des dégâts et donc c'est en fait
faut passer d'une option ou en fait
c'est très simple vous avez une maladie
vous l'a soigné avec un médicament à la
situation
d'abord je fais en sorte que je n'ai pas
de maladie d'où l'écologie
enfin le paysage olfactif et puis quand
il ya un risque
j'utilise d'autres leviers la résistance
chimique mais aussi les micro-organismes
et où le biocontrôle la france fait
partie des pays qui sont très en avance
sur le biocontrôle avec des consortiums
on utilise les maquereaux organismes du
type les coccinelles les micro
organismes qui sont des champignons que
vous apportez pour protéger les cultures
des phéromones fait en sorte que quand
vous avez si vous mangez des pommes par
exemple qui n'ont pas été protégé vous
avez des verts dedans est bon les
protéger des faits romain et des
substances naturelles donc c'est
vraiment une transition c'est au fond la
durée de la transition en attendant et
c'est un peu le dernier tour de table
est ce que vous faites confiance aux
dictateurs pour donner cette dérogation
uniquement à la betterave qui est la
filière en danger aujourd'hui
ou est ce qu'on est en train d'ouvrir la
boîte de pandore puisqu'il ya d'autres
filho d'autres critiques de culture
comme le colza comme le maïs par exemple
qui utilise des pesticides et qu'ils
vont dire moi aussi je veux ma
dérogation après tout on peut pas faire
une voie que pour la betterave
alors aujourd'hui le texte qui a été
présentée par julien de normandie est
pas une proposition de loi qui propose
des dérogations pour toutes les filières
pas uniquement pour pour le pour la
betterave donc apparemment la majorité
voudraient essayer de corriger ça donc
on verra moi j'attends de voir le vote
vous allez le faire juste vous un terme
parce que c'est important ça oui on va
limiter à la betterave c'est bien clair
net et précis ni que la betterave
c'est possible ça constitutionnellement
parce que on va travailler on est en
train de travailler là-dessus pour pour
que pour que ce soit possible
c'est mon chef d'état qu'a donné son
avis sur la proposition de loi avant
pour dire qu'on pouvait pas mettre la
betterave mais on va essayer de porter
les restreindre sa queue pour la
betterave texte bien sûr ça cette source
d'être assuré bah non puisqu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de betteraves en france
sera beaucoup de nicotine et weeds qui
vont être utilisés et donc autant
d'abeilles qui vont disparaître
moi je voudrais revenir sur un dernier
chiffre qu'on a calculé aujourd'hui on
s'est rendu compte que je voulais juste
à l'heure la baisse de rendement au
niveau national est aux alentours de 8,5
pour cent si tu as écouté ses 15% selon
le service que ça discute du ministère
publiée la semaine nous on a fait le
calcul par rapport au voeu autant qu
officiellement le chiffre qui est en
appel
par rapport aux chiffres 77 millions
d'euros que ça va coûter de dédommager
pour leur permettre d'investir dans
l'agro écologie donc c'est un vrai choix
politique
est-ce qu'on aurait autorise les
pesticides tueurs d'abeilles même si
c'est pour trois ans sachant qu'en 2023
on sait que ce sera peut-être pas la
même majorité donc c'est quand même une
une dérogation qui va jusqu'à une
nouvelle majorité donc l'engagement du
ministre de l'agriculture et de la
ministre de l'ecologie qui n'engagent
que nous alors est-ce qu'on donne aux
agriculteurs les moyens de pouvoir faire
autrement
ça coûte 70 7 millions au moment où on
dépensé l'année diam's est ce que vous
dites cela ne tuera pas les abeilles
puisqu'il devait il ne fera pas les 50 à
la suffisance va dans les terres donc
mais oui c'est pas en la matière et
justement du coup les deux les deux
rotations qui suivent ne seront pas sur
des plantes qui fleurissent et donc les
abeilles ne mèneront pas dans la terre
ça va ça va il faut savoir ce que vous
dites soit serré maintenant et ça reste
dans la terre soit séparé maintenant srd
havas dont l'énoncé populaire on va pas
donner de l'attention sur cette question
vous aurez le mot de la fin parce que
c'est intéressant vous êtes à la fois
médecin et citoyens engagés sur sur ce
débat là on sent bien que il est
beaucoup plus large que cette question
de la betterave
on se souvient du glyphosate promesses
présidentielles interdiction en trois
ans elle ne sera pas respecté ses 31
décembre de cette année les trois ans
fait tellement c'est compliqué à une
nouvelle annonce vous avez pas interdire
le glyphosate dans la loi ne pas dans la
loi puisque on voit bien sur quoi ça
débouche mais on fait confiance aux
scientifiques et aux filières mais oui
veilleurs de s'attendre l'interdiction
sony faisait donc donc la promesse
présidentielle sera tenue sur les
enfants de son nom passant pour ne pas
dire à 100% mais ça sera un pas en avant
des impasses on est en pleine mutation
parce que de toute façon c'est
inéluctable il faut passer à ce que
disait monsieur fort justement à
d'autres formes de culture on voit
notamment avec le vin nature avec avec
tout ça c'est important au point de vue
de santé on sait les conséquences
notamment sur la flambée des cancers ou
quand on en parle et qu'on voit la
montée en puissance des pesticides et
insecticides des engrais on voit les
deux courbes sont pratiquement parallèle
avec le donc il faut absolument il faut
absolument trouver des solutions mais je
pense que on est un pays très vaillant
est très courageux et moi j'ai
quand on voit la qualité des
scientifiques il faut encourager ça faut
corriger mais il est en même temps ça
c'est votre job il faut que l'europe
bouge aussi c'est pas possible si d'un
coup la france fait l'effort d'avoir une
meilleure eco logis une meilleure
culture respectueuse de la biodiversité
et puis d'un côté vous avez le pays à
côté qui continue à faire n'importe quoi
une harmonisation faut une harmonisation
et c'est l'europe qui peut apporter
année ce sera le mot de la fin merci
messieurs
j'ai personnellement appris beaucoup de
choses j'espère que c'est aussi votre
cas vous restez avec nous au jeu mathis
mots parce qu'on va parler un peu plus
tard de votre famille politique et en
plein émoi mais d'abord place aux grands
témoins patrick peloux sur tous les
fronts urgentistes et au samu de paris
est devenu chroniqueur à charlie hebdo
[Musique]
alors patrick peloux je disais vous êtes
au coeur de l'actualité
vous subissez plusieurs épreuves de
front on peut le dire
évidemment il ya la crise sanitaire mais
il ya il ya aussi ce procès que vous
suivez également au jour le jour
le procès des attentats contre charlie
hebdo est pas le procès de cyrille donc
bien que d'abord je tiens à le préciser
comment vous vivez psychologiquement
cette période
cc c'est très difficile parce que ça
rappelle de très mauvais souvenirs comme
lorsque je suis allé secourir les
victimes au journal où je travaillais ça
ramène plein de souvenirs pas ce
qu'était qui était merveilleux parce que
ça a été près de 12 13 ans à écrire une
chronique toutes les semaines et c'était
merveilleux c'était une rencontre avec
des gens que j'aime encore et qui était
et qui était formidable qui ont quitté
le journal ou qui sont encore c'est un
choix moi j'ai fait le choix parce que
c'est trop difficile de continuer à
écrire sans sont ce qu'ils sont ou ont
été assassinés
et ce procès ce procès en effet c'est
l'attentât contre charlie hebdo à
montrouge et contre l'hyper cacher qui
était un attentat antisémite et ça veut
dire ça veut dire plein de choses et ça
réveille plein de choses et ça réveille
des combats vous faites bien de le dire
je contribue je l'espère à défendre la
laïcité actuellement avec notamment
zineb el rhazoui alors justement on va
revenir sur tous ses combats
on est allé chercher un petit peu
quelques images qui sont autant de
jalons de votre parcours sinueux et
singulier c'est un portrait signé
clément méric et dès 2003 quand la
canicule s'abat sur la france
un jeune urgentiste lance l'alertent
mais qu'est ce qu'ils foutent de la
direction générale de la santé il se
moque de qui le problème est bien réel
c'est que nous avons des malades qui
sont en train de mourir qui meurent
peut-être plutôt que ce qui devrait mais
il n'aurait pas dû mourir l'homme a le
sens de la formule et cela n'échappe pas
à philippe val directeur de charlie
hebdo à l'époque patrick peloux rejoint
charlie comme chroniqueur l'équipe
apprécie son côté à la fois grande
gueule et hypersensible
c'était un peu surprenant départ de voir
dourges antiste ce matin à écrire c'est
un médecin donc il fait des fautes
d'orthographe c'est un bon chroniqueur
s'est il ramène du réel devises en
bateau on n'appelle pas tout faux pas
trop chatouiller ah bon il peut il peut
tout les coups de banques en 2011 les
locaux du journal sont incendiés après
la publication d'une caricature de
mahomet patrick peloux répondait alors
présents à aucun moment dans le journal
vous trouverez quoi que ce soit de
provocant c'est de l'humour et que je
sache il n'y a aucune loi coranique qui
interdit de rire dès le lendemain charb
et riss sont placés sous protection
policière deux ans plus tard l'un comme
l'autre semble penser que le plus dur
est passé
nous sommes en 2013 lcp avait saisi cet
échange à la rédaction du journal peut
discuter du fait que c'est on n'a pas le
droit de représenter mahomet je n'ai
jamais pu serrer des mains
sinon non mais la nouveauté c'est là
qu'on a gagné c'est que des imams
on commence à dire officiellement enfin
il le savait depuis longtemps mais
commence à le dire publiquement qu'on a
le droit de décider mauvais en tout cas
c'est pas interdit dans les stades
le 7 janvier 2015 les frères kwasi
surgissent et n'ouvrent le feu lors
d'une conférence de rédaction identique
patrick peloux arrive quelques minutes
plus tard l'urgentiste découvre le
massacre impuissant c'est lui qui
annoncera la nouvelle à françois
hollande il a devant lui
des femmes et des hommes qui sont
couchés qui sont pour l'essentiel mort
et il le dit dans un dans un pleur
combien ce qui vient de se passer est
terrible pour lui mais terrible pour
notre pays tout entier
[Musique]
dans ce drame patrick peloux a perdu
celui qu'il considérait comme son frère
charb depuis l'urgentiste a quitté le
journal
et s'il s'est brouillé avec certains il
reste à jamais charger car vous
ressentez regarder tout ça dure c'est
dur c'est dur c'est toujours dur
toujours dur parce que ça active la
mémoire traumatique et tellement de
souvenirs puis de les voir des voir
parler mais ccc c'est très dur c'est
c'est un moment en même temps ça mais
mon de lutte c'est à dire que ouaga ya
plus tellement d'animosité contre les
uns et les autres
c'est juste que c'est juste qu'il faut
qu'on soit tous sur la barricade pour
défendre la laïcité défendre la liberté
d'expression c'est ce qui se dira demain
dans une tribune qui est qui paraît dans
tous les journaux et où c'est bien que
tous les journaux défendre la liberté il
ya liberté d'expression c'est quelque
chose de très important pour ça date d'à
coups y a des il ya des valeurs il ya
des discours on attend toujours ce
discours contre le séparatisme du
président de la république pour des
faits sa oui bien sûr il est attendu ce
discours jean baptiste poux mais déjà je
vois que vous êtes très ému oui est ce
que c'est ces questions là vous tiennent
énormément à coeur et patrick on se
connaît depuis depuis quelques temps moi
j'étais un grand fan et déjà un grand
fan toujours de charlier j'ai lu les
chroniques de patrick roy et jeu on a
une amie commune s'appelle zineb el
rhazoui et patrick mahé fait l'amitié de
venir à l'assemblée nationale où j'avais
projeté justement documentaire sur la
vie de zineb de 2011 jusqu'au travers
les attentats et jusqu'à 2016 on le
comprend sur la vie de mahomet avec
charme
voilà donc c'est une combattante de la
laïcité aussi et voilà et donc je
partage complètement le combat de
patrick sur sur la laïcité et là dessus
il faut vraiment qu'on soit
intransigeant et on l'a vu avec l'adie
république
oui il ya une loi sur la laïcité qui qui
qui va sortir sur la part dont sur le
séparatisme excusez moi cette émotion
qui va sortir là donc on en attend
beaucoup parce qu'il fait c'est plus que
jamais d'actualité
et on voit bien que le dans le danger
islamiste il est toujours là on voit la
drh de de charlie qui aujourd'hui a dû
quitter en dix minutes son appartement
parce qu'elle a reçu des menaces de mort
et ses officiers de sécurité l'ont fait
quitter on voit des comme patrick
ouzineb qui vise encore en france
aujourd'hui encore sous protection
policière en permanence avec des
officiers de sécurité je veux dire c'est
pas mal on doit pas s'habituer ces
gens-là marais cabrette pour ne pas la
nommer
évidemment sont sous la menace et sont
protégés les tous mes deux mondes aussi
la protection voulait aussi
oui bien sûr demande la protection au
fond du pays et des politiques
on va l'écouter l'était sur europe 1 ce
matin il ya un tel climat de 2,2 de
menaces et de 2-2-2 insupportable qu'il
faut que qu'il faut que je quitte son
domicile donc je suis parti je me suis
réfugiée chez des amis en leur disant en
disant bonjour bonjour je viens de
réfugié politique c'est pourquoi on en
arrive à ne même plus pouvoir aborder
tranquillement ses sujets dans ce combat
là où moi je je
j'ai une gêne orage et une colère c'est
fait c'est celle de ma famille politique
ma famille politique c'est la gauche et
ma famille politique je trouve à
abandonner ce combat est d'accord c'est
un requin blanc j'annonce à abandonner
ce combat ah oui oui c'est quelque chose
en diront on dire on dit la même chose
la gauche a confondu accrue je pense que
la fracture remonte à la fin des années
80 début 90 où la gauche pense que si
elle parle de la laïcité elle défend la
laïcité l air
si sts et ça c'est formidable espèces
d'entourloupe et de jeu à l'envers qui a
été pré décidé par des islamistes
notamment de dire mais si vous défendez
la laïcité c'est que vous êtes raciste
et finalement ils inversent le truc
d'ailleurs être défi ministe qu'ils le
disent c'est que d'un coup porter le
voile c'est une dérive du combat
antiraciste et ça et ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été difficile et c'est vrai
que vous dites ça et je suis sûr que
tout à l'heure va y avoir des menaces de
mort sur sur twitter qui arrive sans
arrêt et c'est sans arrêt par ce conflit
avec vous venez de dire là oui oui oui
oui bon la une la une le premier jour du
procès tout ça pour ça vous n'étiez pas
au courant non j'étais au courant
glycation republication va la voir c'est
une des caricatures des caricatures de
mahomet qui ont valu qui nous valut
évidemment la mora au dessinateur de
charlie hebdo
quand vous voyez c'est une là vous dites
quoi le matin vous dites au mont d'or
pour eux ou quel courage
il faut faire ça non il faut faire ça il
faut faire ça parce que mais c'est là où
il ya un intérêt un intérêt public
on n'a pas passé bon sang de bonsoir on
n'a pas passé 19 siècle à combattre les
puissances religieuse pour avoir une
indépendance de pensée on les empêche
pas de croire
la laïcité c'est avant tout la tolérance
c'est tout le monde arrive dans la
république et la république
bienveillante vous permet d'avoir votre
liberté de culte est là vous avez un
député de la majorité
et puis tu es ma chronique en face de
vous vous dites la gauche abonnés ce
combat
madame ses loyers en même temps et de
droite et gauche parce que vous attendez
vous venez de la gauche vous revendiquez
de la gauche oui je viens de vous
attendez de cette majorité aujourd'hui
précisément là l'aï c'est vraiment parce
qu'on a eu ses craintes mais nous en
avons parlé on a on a eu la crainte que
d'un coup il voulait changer la loi 1905
sur la laïcité
or il faut l'a réaffirmé g je participe
et je suis invité c'est un honneur à des
comités laïque où justement faut
réaffirmer la laïcité quand vous voyez
ça a été le témoignage ont détalé avec
zineb el rhazoui à une émission de télé
il y avait alain juppé alain juppé a
délivré ce ce témoignage d'une école où
les parents sont allés protester parce
qu'on faisait et on lisait les les trois
petits cochons à des enfants en disant
c'est pas possible de donner une image
positive du cochon en est contournée en
2021 et cesser ces choses là qu'il faut
combattre parce que c'est un
obscurantisme qui est en train de monter
en puissance au magit morose sans langue
de bois ce ces sujets là il provoque on
a le sentiment parfois un malaise au
sein de votre famille politique
vous avez du mal à parler d'une seule
voix oui complètement non mais je veux
pas le nez dans le temps dans le dans le
groupe et dans l art n ya pas tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord et pas et
affirment passer alors on les les plus
fortement on va dire son parti du groupe
ce qui me va bien
je pars de rien entaché pour être très
clair moi la ligne voilà c'est ce que je
dis mais il ya déjà des divisions n'est
pas tous d'accord et on rit on
s'engueule assez fréquemment sur ces
questions là oui c'est faux il faut être
honnête grande clarification vif
ivan qu il faut une clarification moi je
le prône depuis
des années depuis depuis que je suis lui
faut une clarification sur ce sujet là
il faut que les politiques arrêtent avec
la lâcheté avec l'électoralisme avec la
démagogie sur ces questions là la
laïcité est une valeur de gauche que la
gauche a abandonné en rase campagne
effectivement comme le disait patrick
sur un mythe du racisme de
l'islamophobie qu'une chose qui n'existe
pas donc il faut que la gauche que
qu'ont réaffirmé cet attachement à la
laïcité parce que c'est le seul moyen
aujourd'hui de tenir ensemble les
séparatismes c'est mortifère pour la
république et pour la nation et il faut
aider avantage on attend les actes
j'aimerais quand même il nous reste une
petite minute pour cette partie des
missions qu'on parle un tout petit peu
voilà de cette crise sanitaire louis
frappe et qui dure où on en est samuel
paris où on en est ah bon on en est ça
monte doucement mais c'est pas le grand
pic ou la fameuse deuxième vague plus
catastrophique que la première je pense
que c'est l'évolution normale de
l'épidémie on voit que il se passe
quelque chose
jusqu'où ça va aller on ne sait pas
premièrement nous ne sommes pas comme
aux états unis ou au brésil nous avons
un système de santé qui est quand même
largement plus opérationnel et sur
l'accès aux soins
on connaît deuxièmement connais beaucoup
mieux la maladie que ce qu'on la
connaissait au mois de mars avril donc
d'un coup on s'est mieux soigner on sait
mieux prendre en charge
on est en dessous du niveau de mars
avril les hommes qui deviennent rouges
bas c'est en fait les zones si vous
voulez où le virus n'était pas venu au
printemps donc là il est en train de
venir à l'automne donc on ne la ccc des
incertitudes dans les semaines qui
viennent mais faut quand même voir qu'il
ya une mobilisation qui se fait dans les
hôpitaux
le seul problème qu'on a ça va être le
nombre de lits ouverts et le nombre de
lits de réanimation et c'est là où il
faut que cette fois si vous voulez aussi
garder délai pour les autres services
voilà l'idée voilà parce que s'ils ont
des programmes tout il ya il faut pas
comme au mois d'avril où on se dise
voilà on va soigner que les malades
atteints du coc vide de lakovic 19 c'est
pas possible il ya les autres malades et
aux risques si on reproduit ce schéma de
déprogrammer de plus prendre en charge
les autres malades
on risque d'aggraver la mortalité en
abandonnant les autres malades et pour
ça vous êtes aussi durable
conseil scientifique et son président
jean françois delfraissy pour terminer
pourtant cela dessine une tribune pour
visite soudan le conseil scientifique
gis pas j'ai pas signé cette tribune
mais j'ai dit la même chose sans savoir
qu'ils avaient fait une tribune bon mais
en gros je pense qu'il a vécu il faut on
a une administration qui est remarquable
que je critique mais c'est la liberté
critiqué dans notre pays mais elle est
remarquable faut laisser faire la
direction générale de la santé la
direction des hôpitaux les agences
régionales de santé d'avoir une couche
supplémentaire de technostructure qui
parasitent le discours un petit peu et
qui va pas nous nous étonnons pas
forcément je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire meilleurs spécialistes vous savez
et écouter des infirmières de terrain
c'est souvent aussi d'excellents
spécialistes merci vous restez avec nous
parce que c'est l'heure de parler un
petit peu de ce qui se passe chez vous
jean baptiste moreau on va parler donc
de la république en marche le parti le
groupe parlementaire les difficultés
électorales des missions pourquoi tant
de portes claquent alors thomas des
prêts à passer sa journée à essayer de
comprendre quelque chose n'est-ce pas
thomas où exactement myriam comme vous
l'avez dit avis de tempête sur la macro
ni depuis ce week-end alors avec cédric
dalbar cette après midi on a voulu
savoir si le parti du président la
république en marche marche encore c'est
ma journée à l'assemblée
[Musique]
alors hier soir c'était bureau exécutif
à la république en marche une instance
interne chargée de définir les grandes
orientations du mouvement
et c'est le moment choisi par trois
députés pour annoncer leur décision de
quitter ce bureau père père sont d'abord
il était numéro deux de la république en
marche il a annoncé sa démission hier
matin dans une grande interview au
journal le monde s'en est suivie sacha
ouvriers aurore bergé trois figures
historiques de la république en marche
qui prennent leurs distances avec le
mouvement au moment où le parti doit
affronter des sévère défaite aux
élections législatives partielles
- laurence moment la république en
marche c'est la république à l'arrêt
c'est un peu la trame péters savez on
est en temps un peu dur et il faut
serrer les voiles ça tangue un petit peu
d'en bouger ça bouge encore verger
pierre berson et sasha jolie décide de
partir pour faire un électrochoc ils ont
raison de le faire
d'abord ils partent pas très loin 1 la
dernière fois que j'ai vérifié en
réunion de groupe
tout à l'heure ils étaient là tous les
trois mois ce que je regrette notamment
thann bon c'est que ces interviews de
deux paires sont bien qu'on ait ce débat
en interne c'est important qu'ils aient
des points de vue différents
c'est important ces lois de c'est
souhaitable il voulait aller dans la
presse pour déballer ses affaires
personnelles alors que nous sommes une
nation de crises tellement crucial pour
les français les français ne peuvent pas
comprendre
moi je leur dit à pierre à aurore ou à
sacha si vous êtes là c'est parce qu'il
est la tranche des manuels mercredi ce
climat de pression sur des affiches et
dont peut-être qu'on leur a donné trop
d'importance bon alors ça c'est pour la
forme mais nous on a voulu essayer de
comprendre pourquoi la république en
marche enchaîner les défaites
électorales
on a demandé des explications à sacha
ollier qui a quitté le bureau hier on a
demandé mais il n'a pas été très bavard
monsieur ollier bon ben on a essayé il
veut pas parler
la principale raison de ces débats
internes c'est la gestion du parti par
stanislas guérini le délégué général de
la république en marche sont remis en
cause son organigramme sa stratégie mais
surtout sa ligne politique
or verger a rappelé ce matin si nous ne
savons pas qui nous sommes
nos électeurs ne le seront pas non plus
et elle n'est pas la seule à le penser
une fois que on a dit qu'on était et de
droite et de gauche cela nécessite une
réflexion approfondie sur notre socle
idéologique
savoir ce qu'on fait ensemble le en même
temps s'ils tournent à vide ils ne
signifient strictement rien on vient de
le voir à l'occasion des élections
législatives partielles et donc je pense
qu'effectivement c'est une grande
nécessité que la majorité soit identifié
à quelque chose la république en a marre
je pense trop à droite vous trouvez que
la raison pour laquelle je suis de plus
en plus à gauche voilà meriane la
république en marche ces données a deux
semaines pour faire le diagnostic des
dysfonctionnements internes avant
peut-être d'envisager des solutions et
je salue à âmes ont un gamin sur ce
plateau
bonsoir al-zahf d'être journaliste à la
rédaction des cp vous avez toutes les
informations de la coulisse dans la tête
des députés est ce que c'est une grosse
crise de nerfs est ce que le parti
présidentiel peut imploser vous allez
vous dire tout ça jean baptiste moreau
vous étiez au bureau exécutif
je suis porte parole du mouvement qui a
consacré ces démissions diverses
qu'est ce qui se passe franchement non
mais c'est compliqué on n'est pas
surpris non fait longtemps qu'il ya des
tensions mais c'est pas facile qu'on a
fait on a réuni des gens qui viennent
d'univers politique différent des gens
qui ont un peu d'expérience politique
d'autres camps n'ont pas du tout qui
viennent de la société civile donc on a
mis ensemble des gens qui qui qui n'ont
pas a priori tout pour s'entendre au
départ donc y ait des tensions à des
moments ça me semble assez logique et
assez humain au final kaboul les
tensions les tensions elles portent sur
la ligne politique parce qu'on voit bien
que vous certains viennent de la gauche
c'est un peu le centre de gravité au
groupe parlementaire
la base électorale s'est déporté à
droite où ce sont des querelles de
personnes je pense que voyez un peu de
caurel de personnes évidemment comme
dans toute organisation collective et je
veux dire les que le groupe majoritaire
et que le parti majoritaire et des
difficultés pendant un mandat c'est
enfin je veux dire quand quand je me
regarde je me désole quand je me compare
je me console fin quand on regarde les
partis politiques soit le ps où vous la
droite quand ils ont été au pouvoir ils
ont ils connu des échecs électoraux ils
ont eu des problèmes sont les problèmes
politiques que vous traversez les
problèmes politiques c'est pas tant un
problème de link un problème d'ancrage
on a un mouvement qui neuf qui date de
2016 qui est assez peu ancrées
territorialement oui l échec aux
municipales a fait mal et puis
l'organisation et là je peux je gex
enfin je suis d'accord avec les les
remarques d'une sa tante de remarques de
pierre person ce que je regarde c'est
qu'il ait fait publiquement et c'est
mieux de c'est toujours mieux de régler
la république en marche ne produit pas
d'idées ça c'est fou ça c'est bon c'est
pas des idées on en produit le problème
c'est qu'on sait pas les faire passer
alors je me mets dedans parce que je lui
porte parole mais on n'arrive pas à
faire percolé et dans l'opinion publique
que il ya un travail
il ya un travail des militants à la base
il ya un travail mais on a un mouvement
qui goût grosso modo est trop
centralisée que les choses soient
claires a trop parisien et l'a fait
d'avoir décidé tout depuis paris sur les
élections municipales à créer des
frustrations et des tensions sur le
terrain auprès des marcheurs auprès des
députés aussi qu'ils estiment ne pas
avoir été suffisamment consultés
donc voilà et constate pierre personne
on peut les partager après l'étalé
devant le grand public et expliquer
qu'il faut appeler à la démission moi je
suis désolé quand il ya une tempête le
capitaine il commence pas par sauter
dans le second cas de non sauvetage et
s'en aller il assume je veux dire les
gens qui ont été au beau fixe
ils sont depuis 3h explicatif du
mouvement ils sont depuis trois ans donc
les échecs c'est aussi des échecs de
chacun et je me mets dedans la limite
mais mais mais maintenant on a des
échéances électorales soient
départementale sur les régionales il
faut se remettre en ordre de marche
n'est pas le moment de faire une
élection interne où on va se déchirer et
on va faire la joie de noël journaliste
possibles et imaginables
maintenant les titres sont savoureux à
la réponse est à l'arrêt vous les avez
eu au téléphone
comment comment ils vivent tout ça les
députés de la majorité bien en fait il
ya plusieurs effectivement ligne mais ce
but rex parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un mot qui adore les marcheurs vous
aimez bien ce genre d'abréviations il a
été plutôt mal vécu c'est un peu la
soupe à la grimace
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale
pourquoi il ya plusieurs lignes il ya
ceux en fait ils reprennent une
métaphore un peu sportive on dit le
groupe vit bien pour se moquer un peu de
tous ces entraîneurs de sport qui disent
toujours ça les journalistes politiques
reprennent ce terme à chaque fois qu'il
ya une polémique en interne même vous
les députés pour rigoler vous nous dites
le groupe vit très bien en ce moment
alors qu'on sait que ça se déchirent
après il ya d'autres députés qui sont
quand même un peu navré de voir tout ce
qui se passe c'est une séquence qui
étaient censés sonner une rentrée des
classes
rassemblés autour du modem avec vos
partenaires on arrêtait les dissensions
c'était le plan de relance du coup on ne
parle que de ce qui ne va pas dans votre
groupe
et puis à ce qu'ils se rassurent c'est
un peu comme ce que vous nous avez dit
quand vous vous regardez vous
désolé mais quand vous vous comparez
vous consoler effectivement des anciens
du ps nous disent mais dans les bureaux
nationaux du ps est cent fois pire
donc voilà c'est un cabas passé on peut
qualifier ça si on veut être gentil
d'une crise d'adolescence d'un mouvement
encore jeune si on va être méchant on
peut dire que c'est l'explosion en vol
d'un parti sans idée alors on va essayer
d'être nuancée ici dans ça vous regarde
on va dire qu'en tout cas il ya une
grosse grosse remise en question au sein
du parti en ce moment patrick paulo au
fond le maquereau nisme cemac rond ça
veut dire que ce parti est une écurie
présidentielle est ce que vous pensez
que le chef de l'état a à coeur de
construire un parti politique qui
pourrait lui survivre après tout n'est
pas sûr de gagner
non c'est le chef de l'état il ya eu une
opportunité de devenir président de la
république et il y est maintenant les
résultats sont sont pas au rendez vous
il ya à gérer une crise sanitaire est
énorme
non moi ce que je constate et ce qui me
désole un c'est l'abstention
les résultats là il ya des vins même pas
20 % de son temps c'est pas possible
là vous parlez des délais des élections
était la chose pour les municipales 1%
d'un mois sur moi je n'ai pas vraiment
aux prochaines présidentielles faut
qu'ils aient des candidats qui disent on
rend le vote obligatoire c'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça et
d'avoir un mépris pour ce que représente
la démocratie qu'on a eu un mal fou on a
mis des siècles à conquérir la
démocratie 1 il faut faire vivre la
démocratie les gens ne veulent pas aller
voter mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
luxe prétentieux de ne pas aller voter
alors oui reconnaissons le vote blanc
faisons faisons cette reconnaissance y
légende s'identifie pas mais il faut
rendre le vote obligatoire ce qui se
fait dans certains pays européens
parce qu'il faut sauver la démocratie
sinon avec 20% on va avoir des
tartignole qu'ils vont réussir à prendre
le pouvoir c'est pas possible ça y est
favorable au vote obligatoire je suis
pas content oui je fais là dessus mais
mais après il faut que nous aussi on
n'en met clairement aujourd'hui on
on a été élus sur dépassement des
clivages gauche droite et le fait de
devoir recueillir refleurir un peu
d'aidé usine à champions d'aidé courant
d'être des choses comme ça moi ça me
satisfait pas ses pas c'est pour ça que
j'ai jamais fait partie mais emmanuel
lacroix il est président de tous les
français aujourd'hui il a une crise
économique et une crise à gérer et je
pense qu'on nous aide un peu moins
regarder nos égos et de répondre aux
préoccupations des français parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui se passe au
mouvement s'annonce assez intéresse un
petit monde politique
mais globalement les français ils s'en
foutent ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'on y
arrive et qu'on réussisse et donc c'est
à nous maintenant de de relever les
manches et d'arguer raté de nous
regarder le nombril parce que
franchement ça nous fait avancer
rien dû justement à partir du moment où
on fait les gens ne vont plus voter ça
ne peut pas les intéresser si vous
obligé le peuple moi ce qui me paraît
tout à fait normal dans une modernité de
se dire on va aller voter ils vont
peut-être commencer à se réinvestir dans
la chose politique
parce que la chose politique si la vie
en société c'est l'avis de notre
civilisation c'est notre avenir est là
après après vous pouvez vous pouvez
discuter les gens qui d'un coup se
permettent justement de juger ou de
participer au débat alors qu'ils ne vont
pas voter bas et ben franchement c'est
des lâches car évidemment il ya
l'abstention la défiance est énorme mais
elle est une plage après sondage et
rinaldi on arrive on ne respecte la
démocratie la démocratie et de la
politique
est ce qu'une solution on entend parler
de ça vous nous vous nous dites alsace
est de dépasser la république en marche
dans une forme de super party avec
plusieurs petits partis
les marcheurs et leurs alliés exactement
mais c'est toujours cette volonté avec
en marge de faire un peu différemment
ils ne veulent pas être un parti comme
les autres donc on appellera ça une
confédération
sauf qu'un parti politique ça fonctionne
avec des militants encartés qui paye la
cotisation qui sont sur le terrain qui
vont tracter ça fonctionne moins que ça
fonctionne dans tous partis confondus
vont marcher aujourd'hui ce sont
simplement des internautes des
républiques en marche clairement il faut
que ce soit le pivot de la future
majorité s'est effacé que qu on s'allie
avec d'autres tweed accord mais il faut
déjà que nous on fonctionne si on
fonctionne pas c'est enfin je veux dire
on construit pas un immeuble sur sur de
l'argile et sans fondations je dirais
z'auraient loi de la fin sur sur la
question des départementales et des
régionales c'est une la stratégie de
votre parti questionne beaucoup de
députés est ce qu on fait une liste de
la majorité présidentielle élargie
autour d' en marche
ou est ce qu'on s'accorde avec valérie
pécresse en ile de france le président
rottner dans le grand est et c'est ça
c'est pas tranché les laisser dans six
mois c'est pour moi il faut pas qu'il
soit tranché au niveau national il faut
que ce soit rangé dans chaque
département chaque région chaque chaque
au comité de départementales ou
régionales et chaque député
chaque merde parce qu'on a quand même
des mères la république en marche sont
capables de déterminer quelles
stratégies faut qu'ils emploient sur
leur département sur leur région et moi
c'est ce que c'est ce que ce c'est ce
que je plaide si on veut rapprocher le
citoyen du politique faut que les
décisions se prennent au bon niveau du
citoyen et pas paris et vous avez du
pain sur la planche
objectif ancrage local pour les futures
échéances merci beaucoup
jean-baptiste moreau l amont d'un gab à
bourges dès qu'on voulait et notre grand
témoin patrick paulo c'est un honneur
merci beaucoup merci à vous de venir dès
la fin de cette émission très belle
soirée documentaire et adresse
[Musique]